pull this thing apart see if there's a
soul in their first trailer for ghost in
the shell starry scarlett johansson has
come out i'm not going to talk about the
racial casting i did a full video about
that if you want on my opinions you can
check that out so i'm not even
addressing it here I'm only talking
about this trailer and the impression it
left on me and honestly I'm going to
worry about from by a larger than me
talking about my worries concerns and
things about this that I don't like now
that said this is not a bad trailer and
if I were seeing it in a vacuum without
the baggage of knowing and loving the
original anime as well as standalone
complex then I probably would be very
happy with what I would see but because
I have that baggage because I know the
original film and I know innocence and I
know standalone complex very well and
like all of those very well what I'm
seeing in this that is diverging from
that or layering any things or imitating
too much in some cases that's all stuff
that are all red flags for me now again
if you might have guessed from what I
named already my main knowledge of ghost
Michelle is from the anime works I have
not read the original manga although I
am planning to get around to it very
soon i also have not seen all of the
newer stuff i haven't seen the new
animated anime movie I haven't seen
Oliver eyes I saw the first one didn't
love it so that's where I'm Kim coming
up this thing from now visually most of
it looks really good I like the feel of
the shots they're slow they're
deliberate doesn't look to be cut heavy
now that i like i like them adopting
that more methodical approach because a
very easy way to screw up the story is
to focus in too much on the action and
then it basically just becomes the
matrix the action goes michelle has
always been very good but it's also been
very deliberately paced it's not taste
like an action movie it's got too much
thought too much going on behind the
scenes too much talking but when the
action scenes are there they're great
and that is the general vibe I got off
this trailer so
part is good Scarlett Johansson looks to
be doing fine with the major as she's
written but I'll kind of come back to
that and I really like those sort of
kabuki looking makeup thing I like the
kind of came apart got spidery that was
a cool thing but the first things sort
of trick or might yeah I don't know
about that was seeing the major she took
off her cloak and she had the you know
the skin type flesh tone thing and that
was the first thing was like you should
have altered that more because in my
opinion at least the skin type flesh
don't think it worked in the anime it's
not working for me here and if they were
going to keep the skin type thing I wish
they hadn't have made it flesh tone and
that's one of a couple of things along
with the look of otto and his eyes that
i think just doesn't work as well in
live action yes you can translate it
accurately I think they have in both
cases with the look for the major in
that suit and with batos eyes but
looking at them unlike that's not
pleasing for me to look at it's not
working those are my first red flags the
other ones came up after as it was going
along and we started to get certain
things laid over in the voice-over now
before I dig into this i will add the
caveat that it is possible that this
trailer is not completely accurate that
there are overlaid lines that may not
even appear in the movie that they may
be putting you know they may be breaking
things down and oversimplify it for the
purposes of a trailer in order to get
butts in seats I accept that all that is
possible but I'm not going to judge my
opinion of this film based off what I
think is different about the trailer I'm
going to judge the trailer itself and
what they actually put in front of me
that's what they gave me that's what I'm
going to judge it at this point I'm
going to take them at their word that
this is an accurate representation of
the film so based on that first thing
that was said that made me go was when
the woman said to the major you're the
first of your kind I'm like wait what I
can't remember if that ever came up is
being part of her lore that like she was
one of the first full body sort of
things but even if she was she's not
unique at the time this story is taking
place she's not supposed to be that put
me on high alert and then once I was on
high alert I got really really unnerved
as the thing progressed and we got this
vibe of things said by the villain and
things said by the major that
puts her in this questioning phase now
she should be questioned but she should
be questioning grand philosophical ideas
what is a soul do I have one did I ever
have one did I lose it as I became more
and more physically mechanical do I
still retain that it can it be you know
can it move Kenneth transfer what is the
nature of beach she should be asking all
of this unfortunately the question she's
asking in this trailer are Who am I
where did I come from and that's really
boiling it down that's oversimplifying
that's basically turning the major into
Jason Bourne and I don't like that that
kind of got realized when the villain
went you know they didn't save you they
stole you or track you or whatever it is
he said basically implying that there's
some sort of conspiracy behind her
creation and like there's some part of
her history that she's not allowed to
remember and I don't care about any of
that I don't care about the majors past
I don't want a mystery of her past I
want to know her future I want to know
the trajectory that she's on I want to
know where the questions that she's
asking about the very nature of
existence are leading her in her
evolution as a character and as a
physical embodiment and as a mind that's
what I want I don't want to get hung up
on how she already got to where she is
now if you want to send the thing
further back and build up towards her
asking those big questions that's fine
that's about I actually thinking through
the franchisee building that would make
a lot more sense poor put her sort of
more in the state that she was in
standalone complex and then over time
bring her forward to where she's really
questioning the way she wasn't that
original 90s film but instead you really
I'm getting this conspiracy they're
hiding her pass from her vibe and that
is such a derivative oversimplification
of the questions that she is supposed to
be asking about herself and about the
world and I don't like that I don't like
it at all again I will cop to the
possibility that maybe it's only
oversimplified for the trail and I won't
be in the film but again I'm going to
what they gave me what they gave me is
oversimplified to a point that has me
really really really nervous so high
marks for the visuals overall accepting
the couple little things that I pointed
out but visually I think it's going to
be great I was never worried about the
visual presentation I was sure it was
gonna look great I think the director is
a very good visual storyteller but my
concerns from the very beginning I said
in the very first video I ever made
related to this when they first cast
Scarlett Johansson way way back before
everyone lost their mind over that fact
I said way back then that my concerns
are all about how they're going to
handle the story and those concerns are
not waylaid by this trailer at all in
fact it seems to be confirming a lot of
my fears so there's my thoughts on the
first full goes in the shell trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council beats podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned